- Hey, I'm a do everybody
a big favor right now.
I'm not tellin' on anybody.
I'm not tellin' you anybody that I know.
Fuckin' crazy? That's dry snitchin'.
Everybody get on, oh,
yeah, well, this person,
that person, no, all
the people that know me
that I know, hey, I pay
my homage to in person.
I don't have to pay on no fuckin' camera.
What the fuck is wrong?
Turn that shit off.
(Sharp blowing on cigarette)
- [Mark] All right, Sharp.
- The one and only.
- [Mark] (laughing) Welcome back.
- Took you a second, huh, Church?
You looked for me high and low, man.
You kept bothering me.
- [Mark] Yeah, I did.
- You did, man, you wouldn't
leave me the fuck alone.
- [Mark] Yeah, I thought
you were interesting
first time around.
- Yeah.
That's what made me like
you, too, though, man.
You was persistent like myself.
- [Mark] I don't give up.
- Neither do I.
That make us blood brothers (laughing).
- [Mark] We're both from Detroit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] So we, we talk
on the phone sometimes.
- We do.
- [Mark] We've had some
interesting conversations recently.
The talk about, you live in Vegas.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And the, you got into,
we got into a conversation
about this homeless woman
that you met in the store.
- Phew, you know man,
before I get into that,
I really feel like
people treat people really shitty, man.
And it's not people like myself
who are in the game or people
who even aspire being in the game.
I just watched your average Joe Blow
laugh at a woman that was
hungry, she was cryin', man.
I walk, you know, I walk to the store
in the morning sometimes, man.
Sometimes I slow down and I can, uh,
I can really see things for what it is,
you know, and I always call myself,
hey, not missin' nothin'.
So, in the mornings, you know, I slow down
and take me a stroll to the store.
And this one particular morning, I walk in
and I, uh, I see, I didn't
even notice her man,
'cause I'm, I'm just in my own zone,
I'm just walkin' in, I
know what I'm gettin'.
I'm a simple person.
I get the same thing every time.
I don't change, I don't get anything else.
You know what I'm sayin', Mark?
You know what the fuck I'm sayin', Mark?
- [Mark] Mind your own business.
- Okay, then, there we go, stay with me.
So, we in, I'm in the store,
I walk in and as I grab
what I need to grab,
I come and I stand in line
and so it's a little long
line, you know, unusual
for in the mornings,
but, uh, I walk in there,
I'm walkin' out, I stand in the line
and I just hear this lady just scream.
She just screams outta nowhere, man.
And I look up and it's this, it's this,
you know what I'm sayin',
this Caucasian lady, man,
short hair, dirty, man,
dirty, dirty, dirty.
Don't like she took a bath,
man, for months, for months.
She was black at this point.
It wasn't even dirt.
It's just blackness, you know.
She was standing there and, uh,
my first move was, you know,
I brought my, I brought some cards on me
so I didn't have much cash.
I only got like five, six singles on me.
Ran up to the front of the store,
it's just in me, man.
I ran up to the front of the store,
gave her the five, six singles
as they were kicking her
out because she yelled.
You know, they didn't like that outburst.
But I noticed there was somebody
that was standing in front of the line
that was with me that, when she yelled,
he kind of chuckled,
kind of laughed at her.
Thought it was funny.
You know, this woman was
in here pretty much crying.
She wasn't just begging,
she was crying, pleading.
Just somebody, just show
some type of compassion.
You know I run up there, I
give her five, six dollars,
whatever I could do and
I come back to the line
and it just, I just
couldn't fucking get it out
of my mind that this man in front of me
that calls himself a man
decided to laugh at this woman.
You know, I must've told him,
I said, "You know, you
a real piece of shit."
That, you know, "And all
of you in this store."
I said it loud.
Told every fuckin' body in that store.
I said, "All of you are pieces of shit.
'Cause you rather sit there and laugh
at that woman than help that woman.
It bothered me so much,
man I went to the back.
I don't eat the shit from no corner store,
no gas station.
I went to the back, I
found a deli sandwich,
grabbed her some Lay's potato chips,
a fuckin' big tall
Aquafina water, you know.
It's one of the cheapest ones,
but it's something, it's anything.
Went up there, I paid
for what I could pay for,
I grabbed it and as I ran outside,
she was walkin' up the block.
And, uh, you know what I'm
sayin', I called for her.
I said, "Hey."
She came back up,
and, uh, I was like, "Here, you know what?
I ain't got much but," I
said, "I know you hungry."
You know, I pull out the bag.
I pull the sandwich out,
I pull the chips out,
pull the water out.
I asked her, I could tell she's smoking
on a dirty ass Newport 100.
And I can tell she picked
it up from somewhere.
She ain't just have a pack on her,
you know what I mean.
So I was like, "Hey, you
want some cigarettes?
You got frost, you know what I'm sayin',
I smoke Kools," you know, so I'm,
it probably ain't what she smokes,
but nonetheless, you know,
you need some cigarettes,
I gave her five, six cigarettes.
And she's like, "Yeah,
thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you so much."
And you know she goes to start to walk off
and, you know, I could
tell the store owner
or whatever, you know,
the manager come outside
just to kind of come see, like, you know,
they don't like you
helpin' people, I notice.
They don't like you helpin' people
that are around the stores
and things like that.
So, you know, she starts,
she starts to walk off
and I call her, I say, "Hey."
And she turns around and
I just wanted her to know,
I told her, I said, "Hey,
I just want you to know
that I love you, like I really love you.
And we gonna get through this."
And she started crying
and I don't care about
no fuckin', fuck COVID,
I been walking through
the slums of this shit all my life,
so to me, I walked up, I gave her a hug.
She was cryin', she's
a woman that's cryin',
man, that's hurting.
I couldn't stand to watch that, man.
You know, pimps and gangstas
and drug dealers, you know,
back in the beginning of the time,
we were the people that
helped the community.
You know, when the government
didn't wanna help, you know,
when nobody wanted to
come down and help, man.
We were the ones, that's
the era that I come from.
- [Mark] That's what I remember, as well.
- You know what I'm sayin'?
- Yep.
- I notice man, I could be on the freeway,
traffic's held up.
- [Mark] I'm not sure
about the drug dealers,
but the pimps for sure.
- Pimps, drug dealers.
I've known them all.
I've had people like
that when I was younger
help me along the way, all walks of life
that call theirselves a part
of any type of game, any part of entity.
I'm not gonna leave them out,
whether they would probably
leave my profession out
or who I am.
They probably leave that out today,
oh, they don't wanna mention us.
They wanna away with us,
but you know what?
I respect them.
I respect them for what they do,
whether I understand it
or not doesn't matter.
I respect it.
It's what's kept us going.
- [Mark] What do you make of these new,
like I've been on Figueroa
quite a bit lately
and these tennis shoe
pimps that exist now?
The game has changed so much.
What do you make of these guys?
- Get your weather together,
get your weather together,
get your weather together.
You shouldn't have your
bitch out here, man.
It's some fuckin', what's
them, then fuckin',
them slide-on puff shoes
with the little back,
the little UGGs.
Seen a bitch out there with it.
She didn't have U-G-G, she had U-S-S.
Say what type of shit is this?
I had to ask her.
Matter of fact, I was out on Fig, man,
I got picked up, man,
I came straight from the airport man.
My partner picked me up,
first place we hit, Figueroa.
We go down Figueroa, man,
I seen one of the girls,
man, that was out there.
On your, on "Soft White Underbelly."
- [Mark] Oh, you're talking
about the girl that-
- Yeah, yeah, I don't know her name,
I know, see what I'm sayin'?
She was standing there
and I said, "Hey, baby,
I'm back around here."
And she was just so angry.
She was just so upset.
You know, and I didn't really, uh,
I didn't really know how to take it,
I said, "Baby, why you so mad?"
I had to tell her, "Hey, I love you,"
even though I didn't.
But she needed somebody
to tell her somethin'
'cause she was angry.
Listen, I say this all the time.
I even tell this to people that when I'm,
I'm at a gro... I could
be at a grocery store,
I can be in a mall, I can be anywhere
and I'm sittin' there and
I'm gettin' customer service
and the customer service
just seems shitty.
If you don't like your job, quit.
Why do somethin' that you don't love?
I will never, ever understand that,
no one can ever make me.
- [Mark] So the girls
that work for you tend
to like what they do?
- It's not about what anybody does,
it works for me, Mark.
That's not...
- [Mark] I'm saying, it works for them.
They enjoy what they do.
- You would have to.
I don't even live like that.
I only do things that I love to do.
I don't somethin' to just keep me goin'.
I mean people are out there right now,
they know this, watching
this, just doing shit
to keep you goin'.
Stop.
Stop while you're behind,
'cause you're damn sure not ahead.
- [Mark] So, finish new pimps.
You didn't answer the question.
What do you think of these new,
the new breed of pimp
that are basically just-
- You need to quit.
- They're just drug-
- You need, they need to
get their weather together.
It is what I just told you, Mark.
- [Mark] I know that-
- They need to get their
weather together is this.
- [Mark] Is what?
- Listen, if you're gonna do it,
just tighten up, baby.
I'm not a person that's
gonna sit there and knock you
if you're gonna be in it.
Be in it for real.
Stop perpetratin' to being something
that you know that you're not.
It wasn't us that ruined the game.
It was people allowing
squares into our bubble.
- [Mark] 'Cause the older style pimps
were almost community leaders.
- We were, listen to me, man,
this used to be a secret society, man,
secret society and there
wasn't a lot of us.
It wasn't a lot of us, Mark.
You couldn't, there's fuckin' 400 of 'em
over here in this state,
400 of 'em over here in this state.
No, you had a couple and everybody knew
who everybody was.
So I'm not here to talk
about no names and call,
no, I know who I know and they know me.
And I know some of the greats.
I don't have to name off no names,
'cause I really been with 'em
in times when the cameras go dark
and the curtains close, man.
I've been with some of the best.
We're gonna get this shit out today.
We ain't leavin' until
we do this (laughing).
- [Mark] So, is Only Fans a
threat to the, uh, to you-
- I don't think so.
I don't think so.
I'm not against anything,
listen to me, man.
I'm a man that loves sex.
I love sex.
I love everything about it,
I love everything of what it does,
what it tends to.
I have nothing against an Only Fans.
Hey, if it's gonna, if
it's gonna be lucrative,
let it be lucrative.
I'm not, hey, not against it at all.
At all, I have nothing against Only Fans.
Only Fans is just, I just notice
that it starts bringing everybody about.
You know, you got people that said
they would never to it
before, having Only Fans.
Well, guess what, it's a gateway,
so if you're calling yourself not trying
to be a part of the game
or calling yourself, it's a stepping stone
to hoing, so stop.
That's not what you wanna be considered.
You know it kills me, man.
It fuckin' kills me, Mark.
You ever notice a bitch can go out
and fuck fuckin' Tom,
Ralph, fuckin' Michael,
not even wipe her pussy and go back home
and kiss her man.
You offer her some money for it,
she's fucking appalled, how dare you.
How dare you offer me some, I'm a lady.
No you're not.
No you're not (laughing).
No you're not, stop.
Stop disrespecting real
ones that are in the game.
To the, to the ladies of the night,
I want you to know that I respect you.
It's not a lot of us left, none of us,
from men to women, it's
not a lot of us left,
but I want you to know that I respect you
and I cherish what y'all do.
And if you gotta hold
your money and save it
till you can give it to
somebody real, do it.
Don't play yourself no more.
Save your money.
Put it in the pillowcase,
put it in the fuckin' ground.
I don't give a fuck what you do with it,
but don't give it to these suckers.
Stop givin' it to these suckers, man.
- [Mark] What makes you tick?
What do you get excited about?
- [Sharp] Money.
No, I'm just playin', man.
No, it is the money, but
neither here nor there,
it's my kids.
It's my living everyday life.
Why do the think that pimps, hustlers
or anybody that even lives like that,
why do they think that
we stop livin' like that,
like everything is grimy?
I pay my fucking taxes, too.
I love paying my taxes.
- [Mark] And what do you
say is your occupation
on your tax return?
- [Sharp] Entertainer's consultant.
- [Mark] Very good.
- [Sharp] Sharp Productions.
They send it to me in various forms.
- [Mark] And you pay some taxes?
- Yes.
- Good for you.
- [Sharp] Pay my taxes, I pay.
You got to.
I don't want them people in my doorstep.
Not even, not even the least bit.
You got to, man.
It's 2020 we livin' in.
- [Mark] What do you know now
that you wish you knew
when you were younger?
- [Sharp] How to be more patient.
How to take my time a
little bit more with things.
The only time anything's
ever happened to me
in a fucked up sense or in a way
was only when I got greedy.
It was only when I got greedy.
It was never because I just said, hey,
I'm having enough, eh, I'm out.
It's always 'cause I got greedy.
I'm a, I'm a standard American.
We're all greedy, Mark.
We're all greedy, all of us
and nobody's hands are clean.
I'm just one of the people
that don't mind coming
and sharing my side of dirty hands.
- [Mark] How do you define success?
- Being who you really are
and I don't think that has
anything to do with the money.
Being who you really are,
who you're happy with.
I've said it before not, even in the game,
you know I say not what
the next man thinks
or the next woman thinks,
no, it's about you.
It's about you.
They stand out here and they listen.
They wanna know what I got to say.
They out there, waitin'.
You can't, listen to me,
you can't mimic the real.
You know, you know what I
was, I was, I was thinking
about the other day, man?
You notice how you always,
I notice you'll buy
people Christmas dinner
and Thanksgiving dinner and
things like that, right?
- [Mark] Mm-hmm.
- Do you know that the average American,
the average American throws away 20,
and this is the average
American home, a family,
throws about 20 pounds of food a month?
In every American home.
20 pounds of food, man.
You got people out here,
man, they ain't ate for days.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- For days, Mark.
For days.
But they knock people like me,
and I'm the only one
that's comin' out here
even really trying to help,
even when I'm movin' and groovin', man.
They look at my Godly like.
Man, I wanna...
In fact, people tell me,
man, "I'll kiss your shoes."
You ain't gotta do all that, man.
I wouldn't even make somebody,
I don't give a fuck what you got goin' on,
I would never make you
degrade yourself like that.
Never in my life.
Take what you need and God bless you.
Don't gotta kiss my fuckin' feet.
People don't know what
it's really like, man.
For somebody who lives
in every day toe to toe.
Whether it's in a physical movement
or just a shitty state of mind.
- [Mark] What's the biggest
misconception about you?
Your personality's very big.
- [Mark] That I'm passionate
but they take is as aggression.
What happened to people
really havin' a passion?
I care about what I believe in.
It's like a religion, everybody's got one.
It's like a religion.
I believe in what I believe in.
And I don't have to tell you anything
or have to convince you,
people out in the world
that wanna watch it.
I don't have to convince you nothing.
I'm gonna be who I am
regardless to the fact
that you wanna say this is bad
or it's a bad profession or this is what,
man, stall the bullshit
and kill that shit,
'cause I really don't give a fuck.
I really don't.
Not about anything that you wanna tell me
that I coulda been doing
or shoulda been doing,
I don't care about none
of that, fuck that.
It's not me.
That doesn't make Sharp,
what'd you say earlier? Tick.
Just gettin' around to
answering it for you.
You know what I'm sayin'?
That's not what make Sharp tick, man.
What make Sharp tick is being real
and to me, real is reality.
This is my reality, man.
- [Mark] Yeah, I found it interesting
that there were some
comments on your first video
saying that you were fake,
but we should have mentioned
that you were named pimp of the year
a few years ago at the Player's Ball.
- I've, shit, man, I've won
trophies as far back as '07.
- [Mark] So you're for real.
- 2007, yeah.
What year are we in
now? Where we headed to?
- [Mark] 2021 soon.
- Won my first one, man, 2007.
I've always won prestigious
things, you know.
And you know that's not for
the average mind to understand.
We don't invite you
people so you don't have
to really worry about it, you know.
We don't invite you, we
don't ask you to come attend.
- [Mark] There's a lot of
experts in the comments.
- Oh, my God, I notice
everybody's got something
to say that doesn't
know anything about it.
- [Mark] They don't know anything.
- It's always the person with the least.
- [Mark] Yeah, the pimp world
is such a wide, there's
such a wide range of,
from the top to the bottom.
There's guys like Kenny
Red and the Bishop.
- Guys like myself.
- [Mark] And yourself.
And then you've got the skid row pimps
or the tennis shoe pimps on Figueroa,
who are just basically drug dealers
that have girlfriends
that they're hustling.
- I'll say this, remember when I said
that, uh, I got stuck in a time
and you ever got stuck in a time
that you didn't wanna leave?
- [Mark] Mm-hmm.
- Well, I'm happy and blessed to say
I got stuck in one of the realest times,
because at the time where I got stuck,
it was one of the realest times
of being this.
Now, everybody's just doing it, man,
to get by.
To pay the room.
Just gotta pay the room
for the day, get a sack.
Might be able to get you an outfit.
- [Mark] I think you're easy to misread
because your voice, your presentation
is very, um...
- I'm passionate.
- [Mark] Comes off as aggressive.
- I'm passionate, not combative.
- [Mark] But I find you to be
one of the kindest and most
compassionate people I know.
I mean, you said to me
when you saw me today,
"Thank you for being alive
the same time I'm alive."
Who says that?
- Oh, I appreciate you for everything.
- [Mark] It's beautiful.
- I appreciate you for everything.
- [Mark] No one's ever said that to me.
- Really?
- [Mark] Never, I mean it's beautiful.
- Well, guess what, Mark,
we gonna say it again
for the record.
I am happy to be alive
the same time that you are
and I love you, brother.
- [Mark] Likewise.
- Sure.
Hopefully, you know, we can do more
in the future, you know, I'm not,
I'm not always available,
you know, and, uh,
but if you ever wanna
reach out to me, man,
you ever wanna, you now,
talk like this again
and we can, we can, you
know what I'm sayin',
we can just, you know what I'm sayin',
give our insight together, you know.
- [Mark] I'll come to you next time.
- Come to me next time.
We gonna sit in the backyard.
We gonna do this one next to the pool.
(Mark laughs)
Yeah, man, we gonna do this,
everybody always thinks that man,
he lives on skid row.
Why the fuck do I live on skid row?
Why would you, why would
they even think that.
- [Mark] You've never been to skid row
until I brought you here.
- Aw, I've been to skid row,
I just never lived on it.
- [Mark] Yeah, yeah.
- I've been to skid row,
been through skid row many times.
- [Mark] Yeah, many people-
- I've watched people that I know
get in a bad way I didn't
even fuckin' understand
and land on skid row.
How'd you fall that weak to the knee,
but you know what, that's not my life,
that's not my journey to
sit there and speak on.
All I'm gonna say is, is this.
If you're gonna be in this game,
do it for real.
When I came up in it, it was for real.
Hell, we used to turn Las
Vegas Boulevard into Sunset.
Back then.
It's like fuckin', look like
fuckin' football players, man.
Moving' through cars,
weavin' through traffic, sweatin' bitches.
I swear, man, it was a beautiful thing.
The most that you know, today,
you can't even look like
you do something like this.
Back in the day when I was comin' up, man,
the most that the police would ever say,
they would see you sweatin' some game,
just sweatin' 'em, friendly
sweatin', doing your job.
Most police would say was, "Hey, man, hey,
ease up on the prostitutes, guys."
On the intercom.
They wouldn't stop, wouldn't fuckin' bring
all this extra shit and
controversy into the mix.
These are not pimps.
I'm gonna say that right now.
And I don't, I don't knock anybody,
but it's fucked up when your bitches go
and get somebody else
that ain't in this game
and expect him to act accordingly to it.
How could he ever accept you?
He's not me.
He's not the...
Some of the people that I know.
My roots run deep, man, to this shit.
We can get into that one another time.
This isn't no game.
Haven't I showed you?
And we ain't gotta show,
we ain't gotta show financial nothing.
Me and you both know, am I right, Mark?
- [Mark] I don't-
- You've seen it with me, right?
- [Mark] I've seen what you carry.
- We're okay.
We're gonna be okay, man.
Us, together.
I got a couple questions for you, Mark.
Fuck it, let's get into it.
- [Mark] Let's hear it.
- I got a couple questions for you.
- [Mark] What do you want to know?
- You say, uh, you be out on, uh,
you be out on Figueroa late at night.
Have you ever paid one of
them out there for sex?
- [Mark] No, I have not.
- Never paid for sex not one time?
- [Mark] Sex, no.
- Never, not one time out on Figueroa?
- [Mark] Never.
No, I mean, I look like it because
I'm picking girls up on the street
and I'm driving them away
and I bring them over here
and, uh, there's no bed here,
but, uh, but I bring them
back and I don't know
what that looks like,
but I know what it is.
- Yeah, you know what it is,
but ain't it always what it looks like?
Ain't that what they care about?
It's always what it's looks like, shit.
They care about what this
looks like right now.
- [Mark] Yeah, I don't care.
- And you know what,
that's why I don't care.
- [Mark] I think for myself.
- And that's why I don't care.
I don't care about, I think for myself.
And that's what I want
the viewers to know.
This shit's fuckin' up the game.
These tennis shoe, these
tennis shoe pimps sending
these girls out here for
$40, $50, robbing people,
putting things in their drinks.
What's wrong with you, man?
That is not the game.
We are supposed to be
gentlemen of leisure,
not gentlemen of hey, well,
I claim this neighborhood
and then, you know, I'm
a put my pimpin' down
for a second or I'm a put
my ism down for a second
or I'm a put my hustle down
for a second, your money?
You gonna put your money down for a second
to deal with this Nigel.
No.
Be smarter than that, man.
To all my people out there, man.
Be smarter than that.
Let's reinvent, let's re, let's revamp
what really took place in this game, man.
Let's really revamp that.
The old school ways.
Everybody says they have
they, I've noticed that.
It almost looks like it's divisions.
Everybody wants to move and
oh, they believe this way,
they believe it's supposed
to go this way over here,
to go this way over there.
They believe it's supposed to, man, homie,
it's only one way, Church.
It's only one way.
I've been doin' it for 18 years, man.
18 motherfuckin' years.
It's only one way.
And that's the right way, man.
You dig? That's the right way.
I got one more question for you, though.
- [Mark] Speak.
- Mark gonna like, ha, ha,
that turn back on me, man.
- [Mark] It's fun.
- Are you, are you my friend for real?
- [Mark] I think I am.
- Are you really my friend.
- [Mark] I think I am, yes.
- So you now you can't
manipulate me, right? Ever.
- [Mark] I don't manipulate anybody.
I don't manipulate anybody.
- Ever.
Ever.
Can never, ever.
- [Mark] You would not be
very easy to manipulate.
- Yeah, I don't think so either.
- [Mark] But that's not my thing.
- Okay, just makin' sure.
Just lettin' you know, Mark.
Everybody thought I had a problem
with you last time I noticed.
Everybody thought I had
a, I didn't get that.
- [Mark] I didn't get that either.
- We're the best of friends, right?
- [Mark] Always have been.
- Always have been.
- [Mark] Everybody that
comes in here from Detroit,
especially, I connect with.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] I feel a connection
with anybody from Detroit.
- I was, like I said, man,
I was just-
- [Mark] And Chicago.
- I was, I was born, I
lived in Chicago, man.
Lived in Chicago.
Chicago a crazy place.
It's a fuckin' crazy place, man.
I was back there, I was back
there a while back, man.
Shit, man, I done did it all
up and down State Street.
Shit, I done went and bought furs from,
you know Miss Dianne on Oak Street?
She used to have a little,
she used to have a fur shop
over there off of Oak Street.
- [Mark] I remember seeing it.
- Yeah, I used to mess with her.
- [Mark] You need a fur coat out there.
- Yeah, it was cold.
I remember coming from the
West Coast, man, back then
and shit, this is in March.
Man, I come in, man, you know I'm,
I'm dressed for West Coast,
you know what I'm sayin',
West Coast attire, you know,
I made some, man that
fuckin' air come through,
howlin' through them
big ass, them buildings.
That shit ain't no joke.
That shit ain't no joke out there, man.
I like Chicago. Chicago was cool, man.
- [Mark] It's a great place to come from.
- Yeah. It is.
- [Mark] It's a great place to grow up.
- Yeah.
Seems like the whole world
fucked up today, ain't it?
- [Mark] Yeah, it's been a rough year.
- Yeah, it's COVID.
- [Mark] Well, what do you
think the world needs now?
- A leader like me.
Sharp for president.
I'm just playing (laughing).
No, man, you know, honestly,
all jokes aside, man,
I really feel like
we're fucked either way.
It doesn't matter who we
vote for and that's honest.
That's my honest opinion, man.
Doesn't matter, it's
gonna go bad either way.
It's gonna go sour.
They're already ready for it to go sour.
How is it that, man, we,
we have all, we were the strongest,
we were the most powerfulest
country in the world
from American government, American pimp,
American hustler, American con artist,
American whatever, we
are the best of the best.
We're the best of the best
at what we do over here,
not like every other country.
It's just fucked up to watch all my people
out here hurtin', man.
I'm only one man.
I can't help 'em all, I try.
But I can't help 'em all, Mark.
I can't help 'em all.
I think that we need to
do a better job, man,
within this system
and stop giving people
bullshit ass programs
and thinking that's what gonna get 'em
an out outta here and
out of a fuckin' tent.
That's the problem, man.
They think, oh, a program's
gonna fix everything.
Oh, put 'em in a program,
program, program.
Assessment test, assessment
test, assessment test.
Who's that one girl, man,
I felt real bad for her, man.
Who was that, the girl, uh, Lynn,
was that her name?
- [Mark] Lynn?
- You brought her on a few times.
- [Mark] She's been
here a few times, yeah.
- You know, man, it was something
that resonated with me, because you know
I'm out here, man.
I know how people think
and how we're moving,
especially in a dark world.
She had said something
along the line, she was like
I just want, she says, "I
just wanna fucking die."
See, her mind was already dead.
Spirit was already dead.
She was just waitin' on
her body to catch up.
That's all it is.
A lot of these people out here, man,
right now, just waitin' on
they body to rot right along
with they soul and with they mind
and the government, man, the city.
Fuckin' city of Los
Angeles will watch this.
They put fuckin' cops on the corner,
you hear 'em?
They rather harass people
than fuckin' help people.
You hear that, sirens and
hey, hey, hey, we're the...
Man, is that what you doin' out here?
You know what these
people out here are doin'.
You watch 'em every day.
It's a problem out here, Mark.
There's war with the government.
How's the people of the
United States at war
with its own government?
The shit's sad, man.
But they wanna knock people like me,
knock what I do.
I watch the news just
like everybody else does.
Oh, what, because I decide
to get my money a little bit differently
or I've done things a
little bit differently?
Who fucking gives a shit?
I'm the same like you, Mark,
the same like all these viewers.
It doesn't change.
That doesn't determine me or define me.
This is me, man.
Whether I choose to stop tomorrow or not,
it doesn't fuckin' matter
and it's nobody's concern
who's watching this.
You can suck my balls through the drawers
and you remember that I said that
and I mean that from
the bottom of my heart.
This evil face that you say I'm aggressive
or I'm a, no, I just stand up for me,
a lot of shit you people
don't do these days.
But we're Americans, right?
Land of the free.
Well, why can't I fuckin' freely exercise
my right to keep it ism.
Why they wanna take us down, Mark?
Run us in the ground.
300 years, 400 years,
they're fuckin' handed out
fuckin' slave years.
Now, I'm a person that don't condone, man,
fuckin' with babies or anything even
with teen in it, I don't like it.
That's me.
I don't like anything with teen in it.
Always dealt with grown ups.
We all make our own choices.
Everything is by choice.
Everything is by choice, man.
Nobody's here to force
anybody into anything.
Whether they wanna believe that or not,
think that I'm out here, oh,
he's, he's hurtin', no I already said
I don't wanna be the gorilla.
I'm not the gorilla.
I don't even like bananas.
I'm dead ass serious.
This shit's bigger than me.
Let's point the finger at the people
that's really the trouble, man,
'cause it damn sure ain't me
or any colleague that I know.
Anybody I've ever known
that's ever done somethin'
like this, anything,
it's not us, man.
It's them.
They consider us the circus,
we consider them the fucking zoo.
As much as they watch and laugh at us,
we sit back and we laugh just as hard.
Everybody always wanna
know what's in my cup.
You'll never know.
- [Mark] Champagne?
- Yeah, so you think (laughing).
- [Mark] Well, Sharp, thank
you for coming in again.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] Interesting as always.
- As always.
- [Mark] I hope we do many more of these.
- I love you all, Church.
- Yeah, give it to one us
around this motherfucker.
- Church.
- We real, we real ones around
here, believe that, Jack.
All them comments and shit,
we ain't worried about that,
we in them streets.
Come see us where they get famous at
on the motherfuckin' blade.
- But guess what?
I'm a say this, you won't.
You won't.